spring in Tom Verducci the intrepid
baseball writer Sports Illustrated
senior baseball writer MLB Network MLB
on Fox Tom let me start with this three
batter rule for relief pitchers because
I don't feel that bad that I didn't know
about it because Joe Maddon and let's
see who else
a couple other men Joe Girardi didn't
even know about this did you know about
this yeah well they've been talking
about it and actually almost a year ago
when MLB wants to do this the Union did
not sign off on it but they said okay
we're not we will agree not to challenge
this if you want to implement the rule
so that's where we are now they're going
to implement the rule in 2020 I got to
be honest with you damage there's no two
ways about this I hate this rule I think
baseball is going to a very dangerous
place where you are now telling a
manager there are artificial governors
on how you can run a game in other words
the best moves that you can make the
best win the game now sometimes your
hands would be tied and the example that
I use is last year Game seven of the
World Series AJ Hinch brought will
Harris out there they were up by one
Kendrick hits the home run cabrera it's
a hanging curveball for a single Harris
is absolutely guest it's Game seven of
the World Series the manager can't take
him out of the game because of a stupid
rule that says you have to stay in can
you imagine the NFL somebody telling
dole Belichick a sub goes in the game
and you've got to stay in for three
plays I make no sense
what kind of loopholes do managers have
because I'm wondering if you just say if
I'm a pitcher and if I get roughed up
and my first two batters or I'm my
manager only wants me to stay in for two
batters then I just give a signal one
languege your older is starting to hurt
a little bit here like how are we gonna
get around it because it feels like
there is a loophole or two yeah I mean
you know managers and baseball people
they'll find a way it's there I mean if
a guy complains that he's got a
stomachache or a cramp or or something
that's not gonna turn up on an MRI where
you need proof are you gonna say the guy
was faking it you know that is a
loophole I don't know how often guys
would try it but here's that you were
throwing some numbers out there then
this rule is not worth the cost of
messing with the strategy of the game I
figured
if it were in place in 2019 it would
affect one game every three or four
games in the course of a year about 700
to 800 pitching appearances of one or
two batters that did not finish the
happening you know what that works out
to the average how much time you're
saving in the average game 44 seconds
you are changing the ways a manager can
run a game for the sake of 44 seconds
nobody will notice that nobody okay but
why did they implement these moves
actually well because in 2015 when
things were really getting crazy with
pitching moves you know because lefty
come in and the righty came in that
seemed to get a hand and people just as
baseball people like to do complaining
about it and started extrapolating it
out what's gonna happen next when I have
27 pitchers - 27 out but actually in the
last four years it's gone down by 20
percent it's not nearly the issue that
it was back four years ago so I it's a
solution in search of a problem listen
the biggest biggest problem in baseball
is the time in between pitches
while these pitching changes have been
going down in terms of the short ones
time of game has been going up because
they've added between two and three
seconds per pitch that's 15 to 20
minutes of absolutely nothingness in the
course of the game that's what they have
to address do you think there'll be any
modifications before the start of next
season to this rule well I think it's
such a stupid rule I saw a long push
comes to shove we get to opening day and
they said okay we won't go ahead and
implement it I mean then you got to find
me a manager who a knows about the rules
you just alluded to and B actually likes
the rule what manager would like a rule
that tells him how he can deploy his
personnel to win a baseball game I can't
even think of a rule of baseball went
out of their way to put a handcuff on a
manager for the sake of one pitching
change every three or four games talking
to Tom Verducci is Sports Illustrated
also MLB Network MLB on Fox recap free
agency here where would you start
good wait for Scott Boras you know we
knew he had the three biggest guys
coming in but as opposed to the last few
years when the winters were so slow and
waiting didn't pay off
Scot changes tactics and to his defense
- these were just super players that
where people wanted to get out there
early I thought he did great balky was
getting Strasburg signed back with the
team he wanted to go to with a a
contract that really surprised people
and once that cornerstone was laid then
Gerrit Cole was right on top of that and
then once the Angels didn't get together
they really wanted Cole they pivoted in
a hurry to Rend own so the pace of it
was crazy but I'm not surprised with
where the individual players wound up
but it was kind of a whirlwind there for
the last three days yeah I was surprised
with ren-dono I didn't know if he wanted
to go to the west coast
you mentioned the Dodgers they didn't
get Rendon they didn't get Cole does
that mean they had a bad offseason the
most fascinating team because they've
been in it and been connected to a lot
of huge names and there's many paths
that they could go their priority was
Gerrit Cole they just couldn't win to
record recruiting war with the New York
Yankees Yankees went a little bit
farther in terms of the terms of the
contract
I just quite frankly sold him a little
bit better than Dodgers did you know a
lot of rumors about Lindor winding up in
LA I think it's a perfect fit but I
think it's gotten ridiculous with some
of the names that are being thrown out
there every day there's a different name
Arenado it's bets you know it's one door
it's Seager there's very rarely do these
star players get traded Chris Bryant and
in fact general managers telling me it's
harder than ever to trade big-time names
so what the Dodgers next move is I'm not
sure I think they need another start
pitcher Giants fans would hate this but
I'd love to see madbum in a Dodger
uniform I mean he's the kind of pitcher
that let's face it that that team needs
them not just to get to the playoffs
we've seen that movie before but the
wind the darn thing and right now the
number two started a postseason
environment would be Clayton Kershaw and
you know we know what his track record
is if it was your money and not arty
Marino's and you could have Gerrit Cole
at that price or Anthony Rendon at that
price no I'd go Cole for sure I just
think they they had an uphill battle all
the way the Angels they had to convince
Guerra call that they're going to win
sooner rather than later I mean the
Dodgers and the Yankees have already
made World Series contenders annual just
couldn't do that with
Cole so I do like the way they pivoted
to anthony rendon best position player
on the market I think that team's gonna
be lost fun to watch I know how many
games they'll win but when don't and
trout and Otani betting back to back to
back is pretty cool I would go out get
Dallas Keuchel if I were them because
now with that left side of the infield
with el treinta some Simmons and Brendan
I mean just let a ground balls to the
left side those guys will go get
everything they do need at least another
starting pitcher whether it's Ryu
Michael Bumgarner some good arms out
there trading for Corey Kluber is
definitely in their crosshairs as well
they're not done yet but that was a man
I called it an ankle breaker of a pivot
by the Angels we didn't get Gary Cole
all right let's cook hit Anthony Rendon
we've got more information I guess the
study was done with professors on the
baseballs and we realized that you know
part of the the spike and homeruns had
to do with the seams being raised on
baseball's now is that juicing a
baseball and it differently is it
doctoring a baseball like like what I
don't know who to point a finger at and
say well wait you raised the seams did
you raise them on purpose here and how
much of an impact did that have on
launch angle and drag and all this other
stuff that we're talking about yeah they
said about 60% of this was due to the
lower seams at the baseball 40% is
because of what we've all been watching
the way guys are swinging the bat now
they call it the launch angle of
revolution get the ball in the air more
fly balls more home runs but the seams
are definitely lower why they are that's
that's the question right and your
report did go out of its way to say that
they found nothing no evidence anyway
that this was started intentionally I
think I feel a lot to do with
manufacturing dan that manufacturing
process is just so better that the
baseball's are tighter the seams are
tighter and that makes them lower so a
ball that has lower seamed it's going to
have less drag as it goes in the air and
you say well what kind of a difference
could it make if that makes a lot of
difference on fly balls when you're
talking about another 10 or 15 feet of
carry I think baseball needs to do a
better job and they know this I'm just
maintaining the integrity of the
baseball how they're manufactured how
they're stored they realize that the
ball was flying really far and
surprisingly so last year but they can't
tell us and
the reason why the seams were lower you
know they basically owned Rawlings the
company makes it they supervise the
manufacturing process they have to come
up with ideas or reasons why it's
happening the astros investigation what
do you think the possible punishments
are this is gonna be big Dan
I mean you've probably heard the
Commissioner yesterday say this is the
most thorough investigation the office
of the commissioner in baseball has ever
undertaken I mean when you think about
you know biogenesis down Miami at the
george steinbrenner investigation the
Petros investigation and here we're
talking about you know the mother of all
Commissioner investigation that tells me
this is huge we know that they have more
than 70,000 emails we know that they
have phone records instant messages
they've interviewed more than 70 people
it's like this thing has gone on longer
because they're just buried by a
mountain of just evidence that they have
to go through so I think it's going to
be something like the n-c-double-a
institutional control more than
individual suspensions and find there
probably be some of those too but I
think that the biggest hammer will be on
the Astros in terms of the size of the
fine and how many drastic that they lose
I'm talking about two to three years
worth of first-round draft picks
taking away international traffic's
because the way to hurt baseball teams
now is not to find them as we've seen
this week they've got a lot of money you
really restrict their access to talent
taking away those draft picks that I
think is going to be whatever number
that is how many years that's gonna be
the base hammer but this might be a
silly question and I'll preface this by
saying that could they strip them of the
World Series title no I don't think it's
going that far I don't know Dan that the
evidence listen I don't know what
evidence they have I know some of the
things that we've all read and heard and
seen but I don't think this is going to
say that games in the World Series or
ALCS were influenced directly that's
that's a different animal to try to
really define there I mean all of us
that's the shame of this right it's kind
of like steroids where the guys did or
didn't and the guy has a big homerun
here you say well he must have we don't
know that so that's what's happening
here with the Astros everything that
they've done in now in question even if
not literally everything is but
is on them putting themselves in this
situation where they're subject to such
suspicion and I know I asked this of you
before and you have to tread lightly
because you cover these guys but do you
think it is possible that AJ Hinch did
not know anything about this while
managing the Astros my guess is it's not
possible that he didn't know anything
about it because if you were in the
dugout hard to miss the banging of a
trash can when you're in there you know
especially my understanding is Dan it
went on for about a three month period
in the regular season of 2017 if it was
one game I could say well yeah the
manager might not know it what's going
on but if went on for that period of
time did yes how complicit he was in
this was an active participant and he
discouraged it those are the things we
don't know but awareness of it I would
say absolutely great stuff Tom good to
catch up with you thanks we appreciate
your time it's always great dad thing
that's Tom Verducci
we're tildes rated senior baseball
writer for more Dan Patrick show tune in
to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on be our live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]